good day everybody and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia please allow me to welcome you
to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr david van essen
the alumni endowed professor of
neuroscience at washington university
in st louis dr van essen completed his
bachelor's degree in chemistry in 1967
from the california institute of
technology and in 1971 he completed his
phd in neurobiology from harvard medical
school
his professional experience includes
post-doctoral fellowships at harvard
medical school
the university of oslo and university of
college of london
in england since 1992 he's been based at
washington university
in st louis where he has cultivated an
impressive and successful career in
human and non-human brain anatomy his
model of the hum
the primate visual system is now
enshrined in the historical canon of
neuroscience
and he has made immense contributions to
the field of neural informatics
uh the sharing of primary data and the
processing of neuroimaging data in
particular the computational
modeling and detailed mapping of the
brain's cortical surface
importantly in partnership with dr
camille ugerbill of the university of
minnesota
dr van nessing leads the nih-funded
human connectome project
a massive scale effort to map the extent
and the structural and functional
connectivity of the brain
using neural imaging methods as a
consequence of all his important work to
understand the brain and the role of
computational approaches in so doing
dr van essen has received numerous
awards acknowledgments and recognition
from leading scientific organizations in
the u.s
as well as internationally he's also
held many
major leadership positions helping to
direct research policy and practice for
the brain
its informatics and computation his
lecture today is entitled
mapping structure function and
connectivity in humans and non-human
primate cerebral cortex
as always we are streaming this lecture
live for recording
via youtube if you are watching via
youtube
we welcome you and thank you for joining
us also
for our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
you are encouraged to submit any
questions for dr vanessa via the chat
feature
in your zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions
and i will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of dr
vanessa's lecture
and with that welcome david we are very
much looking forward to your lecture
thank you jack for that generous
introduction for the chance to talk to
you
about the cerebral cortex and structure
function and connectivity issues that
i've been
engaged in for many years now
i'd like to start with some big
questions about how does the brain
work to make us unique as a species
unique as individuals
gifted with amazingly diverse talents
unfortunately afflicted by devastating
brain disorders
at all ages and stages of the lifespan
i think we can all agree that
deciphering the brain and health and
disease is truly a grand
challenge for this century if not the
millennium beyond
i also want to emphasize in this talk
how there's increasing dependence on
data science to move the
needle forward and these challenging
issues
so i'm going to focus on healthy brains
and the cerebral cortex
and the neuroinformatics aspects of how
we tackle these issues
i'd like to start with some basic
numbers i love
anatomy and numbers about the brain we
all have about
three pounds of squishy tissue inside
our skull
and the brain contains uh almost 100
billion neurons
the dominant structure whether you look
at it from the lateral aspect
or the slice through from a coronal
plane
or a medial aspect of one hemisphere the
dominant structure is the cerebral
cortex
which contains about 80 percent of brain
mass if you count the gray matter and
white matter together
and it is of course responsible for an
enormous diversity of
functions cognitive sensory perceptual
motor
and so on uh it does its job
using only about 20 percent of the
brain's total number of neurons
and that's because it's a chock-a-block
full
of 10 000 or so synapses per neuron and
150 trillion or so grand total
the white matter cabling uh linking one
gray matter region to another
contains on the order of 160 000
kilometers worth of
myelinated axons the pint-sized
cerebellum on the lower left
is only about 10 of the brain's mass yet
it contains an amazing 80 percent of the
neuronal total
and it works in coordination with
cerebral cortex and other circuits
to coordinate our movements and also our
thoughts
the rest of the brain is less than 10
of brain mass contains fewer than one
percent of all the neuronal counts
and it contains literally hundreds of
uh subcortical nuclei and subnuclei
that are collectively responsible for
quite a
wide variety of critically important
housekeeping functions
to handle our thirst and hunger and
many other drives and behaviors
so for this talk we're going to start
with some basics about cortical
cartography how we make
maps past and present how we look at
cortical connectivity in animal models
the second big chunk will be on the
human connective project that jack has
already introduced
and then i'll talk about data sharing
and neuroinformatics aspects before we
wrap it up and
have time for questions so our brains
are about three times larger than
that of our closest living relative the
chimpanzee
we're 15 times larger than the
intensively studied macaque monkey that
you'll hear more
about 200 times larger than the
marmoset of increasingly popular
experimental
preparation for primate studies and 2
000
times larger than the intensively
studied mouse brain
you can also see at a glance that the
cortical convolutions vary enormously in
the degree of folding and the pattern of
folding
and it's those folds that made me a
cortical cartographer when i started
working
almost 50 years ago on the macaque
monkeys cerebral cortex
and i took a cue from cartographers of
the earth's surface where we take a
a corrugated
spherical surface of the earth and
flatten it out
and display on maps of the earth flat
maps
many different types of geographic
political and cultural and
economic varieties of information
for the cerebral cortex when i started
the computers weren't up to the job and
so i literally had to
invent a method using pencil and tracing
paper
to make the early uh vintage flat maps
of
here the mount the monkey cerebral
cortex where we
showed the geography by representing and
gray the regions that are buried in
soulside
but we could take these maps and
represent
information about the functional
organization of the cerebral cortex
by identifying various cortical areas
based on information about function
architecture connectivity
and or topography and there were a few
areas like
primary visual cortex v1 and little red
area mt in the middle
that were poster children because they
could be identified
by any or all of these different
approaches and they gave pretty much the
same
answer but most of the other areas on
this
this map although the borders were drawn
sharply on
on the representation uh the data
behind them was fuzzy and there was a
lot of debate about what was one area or
another
we'll come back to that because it's
critically important to have
maps as accurate as possible we also dan
fellman and i
looked in the early days at the
connectivity inferred from studies
reported in the literature and we
identified at that time
hundreds of pathways just among the
several dozen visual areas known at the
time
and we posited this hypothesis that the
connectivity supported the idea of a
distributed hierarchy in which
various visual areas are early middle or
late stages of
information processing and we generated
a binary connectivity matrix
showing the presence or absence of
pathways known at the time
we knew that connections varied in
strength but didn't have any hard data
on that so we had to put that on
hold but you'll we'll come back to that
because it's very important
but to make progress in the field it was
really important to get better
methods of map making and when
structural
mri imaging came on the scene in the
1990s
various labs ours included started
making cortical surface models using
computational methods
and the leading methods nowadays is
without question the free surfer method
pioneered by bruce fishel and colleagues
and uh that method with high quality h
human connection project hcp data uh
lets us
uh capture uh the outside and inner
surfaces of the
of the cortical sheet the cortical
ribbon
and then to take the middle of that
surface and make a
geometric model that we can spin around
and also inflate
so to as we smooth it out the regions
that are darker
on the smooth surface were deeper in the
original
3d brain if we do this for
many different individuals and take a
look at the these
issues of individual variability from
one person to the next of healthy young
adults
we see that they aren't all the same
they're like different fingerprint
patterns
and we can see those similarities and
differences more easily by
looking at the inflated maps on the
right where again the darker it is the
deeper it
was in the 3d uh original configuration
so in some regions like the red arrow
pointing to the central sulcus everyone
has the same sulcus in about the same
region
but actually in most regions there is
remarkable variability in the folding
pattern from one person
to the next and amazingly that's true
even in
identical twins so lo and behold there's
two pairs of twins here
it's very hard to tell until i give you
the cheat sheet answer and you can
be informed that the left and right
pairs here
are from two twin pairs
and there is actually some heritability
when you look very carefully but what
once
is struck by is uh the the striking
degree of differences
even amongst uh identical twins
working with the same genetic
instruction kit
another critically important issue is
that cortical areas
vary in size so in this lower right
panel
the red outlines the primary visual
cortex in the left and right
hemispheres from three different
individuals and you can see
these these differences in size and also
the differences in relation to nearby
folds
that springs to mind a question of what
is it that makes the cortex fold
and i have a story that i'm going to
encapsulate down to a simple nutshell
summary uh i hypothesized some years ago
and i'm currently revisiting this the
idea that mechanical tension along the
axons that connect one
region to another across long distances
if those axons are under mechanical
tension they may be the physical force
that drives the the folding
uh in a systematic way but i'm going to
skip over
further discussion of that and move
ourselves on to the
question of cortical connectivity
returning to what i'd
schematize a little while a while back
uh when we looked at
original brain maps uh
in order to look at the connectivity
systematically we need better
more accurate maps of the underlying
cortical organization
so i mentioned that the map on the upper
left
was an initial approximation uh there
are more recent models
including a 91 area parcellation
shown in the upper right based on
cortical architecture
another one that contains 164 areas
by a different investigator paxinos
some years ago we synthesized a hybrid
across
several different sets and and generated
what we call a composite
map but the reality is for the macaque
monkey we still don't have an accurate
map of all the cortical areas
and we'll see in contrast there's been
more progress on
in other species the mouse and human
to be specific but using the
parselations at hand
we can look more closely at these issues
of cortical connectivity
by taking a tracer injection shown here
for an example area if we inject a
retrograde tracer into cortical area 7a
and then slice up the brain postmortem
the red dots and the
next panel here show the location of
retrograde
labeled cells at various distances
across each slice and when we stack
those together and assign
the total number of area of labeled
cells
for each cortical area we get on the
lower left
a quantitative map colorized to show the
density of inputs from different
cortical areas to the injected area 7a
this is actually a logarithmic plot and
on the lower right
you see that there's an amazingly
systematic log normal
distribution such that the strongest
connections
on the upper left are literally five
orders of magnitude
uh more dense than neuronal inputs
than the weakest connections coming from
the lower right
so this is a basic principle that holds
for all cortical areas that have been
examined
we can also take data that's currently
available from 29 injected areas
out of this 91 area parcellation and see
now a quantitative connectivity matrix
it gives us
a a much more accurate assessment
of the the wiring
that underlies cortical circuits and
brain function
there's still need to
assess this using even more accurate
methods that
are what we call parcelation free and
getting those more accurate connectivity
maps with something our lab is currently
doing in collaboration with henry
kennedy in france
if we take the same issue and apply it
for the mouse brain that i
alluded to a few moments ago
in the upper panel there you see a
top-down view of both hemispheres of the
smooth brain glycophallic
mouse cortex much smaller much smoother
and andreas burkhalter has pioneered the
process of taking that smooth brain and
literally physically flattening it not
computationally but squishing it between
glass slides and then cutting the brain
the smoothed out cortex
tangentially and using anatomical
methods he's been able to identify
41 distinct cortical areas and we think
this is actually pretty close to a
ground truth estimate
of the parcellation in to
many distinct areas but not nearly as
many as in primates
and uh working also with henry kennedy
andreas
and burkholder and colleagues have
identified uh
even richer denser connectivity within
the cortical
network in the mouse so nearly all areas
are connected with all
other areas the only ones that have no
connections are the
scattered ones shown in black there so
the cortex is in this sense a densely
connected distributed network
also amazingly it's now possible to
reconstruct using different anatomical
techniques
the full complexity of individual
neurons so in in the red arrow that's
pointing to a single
labeled neuron in motor cortex
of the mouse and right next to the arrow
you can see that
the distribution of the dendritic arbors
in the immediate vicinity
but then branching out is a single axon
that branches profusely
and makes a huge number of connections
on both the ipsilateral and
contralateral side so this gives you
a sense of what individual neurons are
doing and now think of billions of them
finding their pathways and setting up
shop and communicating with one another
it gives you an idea of the staggering
complexity
that we have to grapple with in trying
to understand
how any brain works
and that brings me in into
an exciting modern world of connectomics
the principle of systematically looking
at connectivity as comprehensively as
possible
but we have to put that comprehensive in
quotes because
the challenges of working with the
scales from microscopic to macroscopic
uh pose uh exciting
uh daunting but uh also
challenges that can be tackled so
there's an exciting world
of the so-called microconnectome that
strives to
use electron microscopy and other ultra
high resolution methods
to identify every single synapse
axon dendrite glial cell cell body the
whole kit and caboodle
and reconstruct that as extensively and
accurately as possible
and there has been exciting
progress and success in reconstructing
the microconnectum
for up to a cubic millimeter
already and in the offing in the decade
or so to come
is the prospect of reconstructing the
entire mouse brain
at the microconnectum level so that will
be uh
very exciting and and something to from
a data science
perspective uh to salivate about uh
the the ways to explore that using
sophisticated
uh tools there is in parallel this
uh second world of what uh i like to
call the mesoconnectome using the kinds
of pathway tracers that i've already
illustrated
looking at local and long-distance
connectivity across the whole
brain at a light microscopic
resolution to identify connectivity
in experimental animals the mouse
and marmoset and macaque monkey
included i currently live
most of my research time in the macro
connecting world
of human neural imaging where we use mri
based
methods for the most part uh to
infer what we can about structure
function and connectivity
uh in living human brains with
the resolution element the voxels we
work with
generally being on the order a
millimeter or two on a side
uh and bear in mind uh that each cubic
millimeter contains literally hundreds
of thousands
of neurons and millions and millions
of uh synapses so our resolution
has to cope with
with those anatomical realities so
but that's the realm of the human
connectome project to which will now
turn our connection
but i want to say a little bit more uh
actually we're going to jump right to
the human connection project now
so
a decade ago the nih funded two
human connect home projects jack was
involved with one
ucla then usc working with mass general
hospital
i was involved with the washington
university minnesota and oxford
consortium where we
aspired to get data on brain structure
function and connectivity
in 1200 healthy adult twins and their
siblings
using state-of-the-art scanners improved
pulse sequences to get higher quality
data
and getting an unprecedented four hours
worth of multimodal imaging data from
each subject
we ended up successfully getting data on
1100 subjects
scanned with the three tesla scanner at
washu
uh 200 of those subjects also flew up to
minnesota and were scanned at higher
resolution with the seven tesla scanner
uh a hundred of the participants went
over to saint louis university and got
magnetoencephalography scanning which is
exciting because it gives much higher
resolution
in time but at the price of a coarser
resolution in space but it's it is
another complementary modality
in addition we got extensive behavioral
demographic and genotyping data
uh to buttress uh the imaging data that
i'll be
mainly focused on when we analyzed the
data we
developed and uh consolidated a set of
pre-processing pipelines that
are absolutely critical for taking full
advantage
of the high quality imaging data that we
were able to acquire
and i'll illustrate how we were able to
achieve improved alignment across
subjects
mapped to more accurate atlases and
bring
powerful visualization tools including
the connect
and workbench platform that mylab has
spearheaded
and we developed advanced analysis
methods for looking at
relationships between connectivity and
behavior and looking at more accurate
cortical parcelations that i'll
illustrate in a short while another key
issue is our
enthusiasm about sharing the data as
well as the methods and tools
i'll illustrate the connectum db uh
database for sharing the primary and
minimally preprocessed data
as well as the balsa database that
facilitates
uh sharing of how to
analyze data and almost twenty thousand
advance
investigators have signed on to using
the the data
and uh more than a thousand publications
uh uh emerged today uh using this
data sets uh
the the neural imaging paradigm that we
introduced as we developed uh these
these methods and and analysis
strategies
uh are summarized with seven core
tenants that
are published in nature neuroscience
paper that i encourage people to look at
the first of them is i've touched on
before
it's really important to get as much
neuroimaging data as one can in any
given study subject to practical
constraints of costs
and and subject tolerance but it needs
not only a lot of data but multiple
modalities
so that they can complement one another
and for each
modality it's really important to get
the highest spatial resolution
possible given again scanner and other
practical limits
and to pay attention to other aspects of
data quality
we found that the multiband mri for
functional and diffusion imaging
uh is extremely important and
essentially
providing more bang for the buck uh
getting more data per
per second yields
excellent benefits once the data is
acquired it's really important to
minimize the distortions which lurk in
most modalities of the data and also be
attentive to not blurring the data so
as not to waste the high quality
resolution that one
acquired another important principle is
to respect the geometry of brain
structures and by that i mean
for the cerebral cortex you've already
seen
visually the benefits of using surface
models
and that's all well and good but for the
subcortical structures
which lurk inside the cortical
core it's really important to use
volume elements voxels and we developed
a hybrid
representation that we call the safety
format
that combines the benefits of growth
approaches and
an efficient strategy once one has data
as analyzed as carefully as possible
across individuals
it's really important to align the data
precisely across individuals and across
studies and and that's not has not been
traditionally done with conventional
volume based imaging
but i'll illustrate the benefits of
doing it carefully
and when the data have been analyzed
it's really important to use accurate
brain parcelations
to the degree that's feasible for any
given species
and lastly but certainly not leastly the
principle of freely sharing the data
from the raw to minimally preprocessed
to publication related
is critically important and is now much
more feasible than it was
a few years ago so let me illustrate uh
by a few examples of why it's so
important
and valuable to get high quality data
and
process it carefully so when matt
glasser came to my lab
more than a decade ago he had actually
noticed
anecdotally that in a conventional t1
weighted image
such as this horizontal slice through
the top of a brain
that in the cortical gray matter ribbon
some regions are a little bit darker
than average
other regions are a little bit brighter
than average and
very importantly if you take a t2
weighted image
uh that looks uh like this next slice
here
it has essentially the opposite contrast
the csf is bright the gray matter is
gray and white matter is dark but in
that gray matter ribbon the region that
had been
darker in a t1 weighted is now brighter
in the t2
and vice versa for the other
example region so by taking the ratio of
that
and colorizing it it cancelled out some
inconvenient biases
and allowed for more accurate mapping of
the t1 to t2 ratio onto the cortical
ribbon
which revealed a pattern that was
strikingly similar to
myelin maps that had been evident from
classical
brain studies so the sensory motor strip
auditory cortex and visual area mt
are all known to be heavily myelinated
and they show up with
with a high t1 the t2 ratio so it's not
a perfect quantitative marker but it's a
qualitatively extremely useful
especially if one aligns accurately
across many subjects
one gets these kind of beautiful myelin
maps that you see
on the left panels here and
uh in the same subjects one can also
get a different anatomical marker of
cortical thickness
as shown in the the middle panel uh the
right panel shows the range of thickness
uh from
uh over about a twofold range
from less than two to up to four
millimeters
and so each of these patterns uh gives
us uh strong indications
of regional differences and by taking
the spatial gradient
and computing that and analyzing it
carefully one can identify
aerial features and prospective aerial
boundaries that run along
what we call gradient ridges and
one can use that to identify just with
these two anatomical methods
some cortical areas but in the
bluish and indigo regions uh the
fluctuations in myelin and thickness are
are more gradual and
less revealing about functional
organization
so that's comes back to this point why
do we need many modalities
it's informative in many ways and
including for the issue of cortical
parcelation
that we'll come back to in a short while
but let's take a look at these other
modalities starting with diffusion
imaging and then
after touching on that briefly looking
at a second modality of functional
mri so uh with diffusion imaging
the action is mainly in the white matter
and as you may know
the diffusion and coating ingredients
are structured in such a way they probe
the the for the orientation or access on
which water diffuses
most freely most rapidly and that
correlates with the
orientation of axons
fiber bundles in the white matter so for
each little voxel
of one and a quarter millimeters we were
able to get for the hcp
one can estimate the dominant
orientation but also
a probe for evidence of whether there
are crossing fiber bundles
which is hugely important because there
are
indeed many fiber bundles
crisscrossing throughout the white
matter organization
and then one can use probabilistic
tractography methods
to infer trajectories of fiber bundles
uh
including those that are crossing
through
any given voxel so one can uh
carry out this tractography approach to
estimate long distance connections from
one seed region in the
blue dot shown in the example uh to
other regions
and one can infer uh gray matter to gray
matter connectivity as shown in
by the reddish regions uh in the lower
right panel here
so it's exciting that one can get
information
indicative of trajectories within the
white matter
and grave matter degree matter of
connectivity
but lurking under these pretty pictures
are some hard-nosed realities
which in a nutshell are that there are
many false positives and false negatives
and systematic biases
even in the best tractography data uh to
date and so one has to be extremely
careful
uh to not over interpret
the data that comes from this and it's a
really complex issue if you have more
questions i'd be happy to
touch on them further in the discussion
period but in the interest of
time let's move on to functional
mri which comes in two flavors the first
of them is
the the conventional task evoke
functional
fmri to use a structured task to
modulate uh oxygen
consumption and the so-called
bold blood oxygen level dependent signal
that fmri yields and deanna barch
pioneer
spearheaded how we approach this with
the
hcp project in the hours worth of
time allocated to task fmri we carried
out seven different tasks
i'm going to very quickly illustrate
three of them
language tasks listening to stories in
the scanner versus doing arithmetic
mentally
a social cognition task looking at
moving triangles and saying are they
moving randomly
or are they hugging and kissing and
dancing in a way that one infers
social interactions amongst these icons
lastly working memory task
is the image you see right now the same
or different from what you saw
two images two back ago
we're gonna fly through this looking at
maps of functional mri task evoked
signals
on maps of the cortical surface that
have been smoothed out on the left
brain slices and mapped to a cerebellar
flat map on the right panels
so here's what happens listening to
stories versus a bass line
you see the reddish and yellow regions
of high activation
in temporal and frontal cortex
evident in a symmetric pattern when both
hemispheres though stronger on the left
uh hot spots indicated by the arrows
also in the cerebellum is uh language
related
regions as well if you take the next
task in line the social versus random
that i mentioned
you see there's partial overlap some of
the regions are strongly activated by
both tasks but many other regions are
activated
in the social versus random that are not
seen in the in the tap in the language
activation
uh and the third quick example uh is the
working memory tasks
that's more complementary but still a
bit of overlap
but basically uh the long and short of
it
that we have time to touch on here is
that for any given task that you're
doing in the scanner or in your daily
activities it invokes a complex
set of partially overlapping and dynamic
networks not just one hot spot when
you're thinking about what's
two plus two and another hotspot four
seven minus four and so on
it's a very divergent
complex network in some ways
akin to the complexity of network of
anatomical connectivity
i've illustrated in the first part of
the top
switching over to our uh next major and
last major modality
uh resting state fmri if one lies in the
scanner and thinks about who won the
game
how is the debate what for dinner uh
what are we going to do tomorrow
the brain is very active and
that's those fluctuations that occur
can be probed uh in a systematic way
by taking any pair of gray matter
regions
gray ordinance as we call them looking
at the time
signature the fluctuations and asking
for each pair
of all possible pairs are they
correlated anti-correlated or where in
between
and that can be converted into a
functional connectivity
matrix as we call it also a dense
functional
connectome by another lingo
that we can see as a this matrix or we
can probe it interrogated
one row or column at a time and say for
seed region one who is it correlated
with and it turns out there's a
systematic pattern
consistent in broad strokes with the
anatomical
patterns we've seen in the in the monkey
regions that are
close to the seed region tend to be more
likely to be correlated
but some long distance regions are
highly correlated as well
on the same as well as opposite
hemispheres
and for another seed region you see a
different pattern
and one can milk that for many good
purposes
even recognizing that this functional
connectivity
measure is really highly indirect and
assuredly is
by not the same uh in a quantitative
sense as tracer-based anatomical
connectivity
something we're very interested in but i
don't have time to talk about it but you
can ask me later if you're interested
so how can we use these multiple types
of information
for interesting analyses i don't have
time
only to talk about one that's my
favorite which is the issue of cortical
parcelation that you've heard about
already
in other species if we come to this uh
for the human
brain uh we're bequeathed with a
century-old
classic map based on just the cellular
architecture or cyto architecture
that the great german anatomist brodemon
painted onto
a surface model or a surface drawing
also a century ago working in parallel a
cecil and auto vote identified
almost 200 areas using milan sane
versus brodemont's map of 50 areas and
for a century
the debate followed as to which one was
more likely to be accurate in
recent decades mri has chimed in with
indications of functional connectivity
maps giving
evidence for network organization
of an intermediate kind of pattern randy
buckner's lab
uh has provided one parselation shown in
the lower left panel
st peterson's lab has produced an even
finer grain
model but that's incomplete and
also not as symmetric across hemispheres
as one might expect
but these uh fmri based
essentially unimodal parcellations
represent major forward progress
but don't provide as consensus within
themselves
and when matt glasser and i uh
focused more intensely on the hcp data
we found that it was possible to get
more accurate partialization
by taking advantage of the multiple
modal
types of data you've already seen
looking for information about
architecture as well as topography and
connectivity and function
in combination and to let regions be
defined
when there's consistency of
radiant ridges that agree across
modalities
uh then we were more confident that we
were on the right track
uh and as you'll see briefly that
proved to be successful not only for
getting a group average of participation
but for individual subjects as well
so to cut to the chase after an intense
uh and
very focused analysis matt was able to
identify
180 cortical areas in the left
hemisphere
a matching set in 180 areas in the right
hemisphere
functionally organized by
broad color schemes to show regions
related to vision
sensory motor auditory or more cognitive
regions
as colorized on the map
we gave each of these areas labels 83 of
them agreed
with classical names in the literature
so we just
was kept with the same name 97 of them
uh were fine or grain or entirely new
uh and so that uh summed up the total
uh as you see on the map there uh matt
was able to apply an aerial classifier
algorithm to identify these areas in in
all individuals
and show that they vary in size shape
and precise location
so just give you a quick flavor of that
here's a group average parcelation
late overlaid on a group average myelin
map
here's one individual subject's
parcelation overlaid on its own subject
particulation and myelin map here's one
particular area
here in another individual you can see
the same area but it doesn't have the
precisely same
location uh
another group allen and tijevitz and
michael cole were able to take
the acp data and identify
uh functional resting state networks of
the type that
the buckner and peterson labs had
previously
uh pioneered but now uh
using uh matt's parcelation to identify
12 distinct resting state networks in
the human
brain as assessed by this approach
so in the last few minutes
let me move on to these exciting and
really important issues of uh
neuromatics aspects of
that were coming from here and i want to
start with one that builds off the
cortical parcellation that i just saw
you because
i just showed you a lot of people have
been interested in
and not just seeing the pretty pictures
in a nature paper
but actually working with these uh data
sets the part the partial laser itself
and the
and the functional and other modalities
of maps and we've made it really easy
for people to do that if you
literally look at the online
journal and look at the figure legend
there's a little url sitting there and
if you click on that you jump
immediately over to our balsa database
which gives you a preview of that same
figure and basically
lets you tap into this by logging on to
valsa which is easy and just saying i'd
like to
after i've agreed to the data use terms
i'd like to download that data set and
lo and behold you can download
the data and launch connect on workbench
and replicate that very same figure
uh and work with the data and the
subsets uh
that you want for your your own analyses
and you can take
other uh as we call them scene files
that characterize
each of these figures and you can get a
scene file with all the labels painted
on the surface
for aid in identifying identifying one
area versus another
so the balsa database is now uh
encouraging peop investigators for uh
all neuro imaging
uh studies to uh work with the connect
and workbench
scene file platform upload your data uh
and share it with the work with the
community
and and uh over 2200 users have tapped
into the
dozens of studies that are in the
database so far but we'd like to build
that up
uh more aggressively in the in the years
to come
and i emphasize that these scene files
are useful
not only for data sharing but for just
in-house working with complex datasets
and making
uh sophisticated accurate figure
preparation
[Music]
jumping over to the earlier stages of
processing dan marcus at washu
spearheaded the establishment of a
robust connectome db
database that is how we shared the
particularly the minimally preprocessed
hcp data
and the connectompb provides for
rapid easy access to
various combinations of data prepackaged
data sets
or drilling down and searching for
individual subjects
or groups of subjects meeting a
particular behavioral or
imaging quality or other aspects of
the acp metadata that we provide
to work with these data sets and
literally
14 petabytes of data have been
downlighted downloaded by almost twenty
thousand
uh users uh to work with the hcp data
and generate the the thousand plus
publications i
already alluded to
so moving uh forward from the original
young adult
acp which wrapped up in 2016
there are many other projects that are
acquiring and sharing hcp style data
that i've
touched upon the lifespan projects in
aging and development
are going to be wrapping up next spring
to provide and share data from more than
a thousand
older adults for the aging projects and
young children five to twenty one
for the development project
a major release coming in a month or so
and then one final one at the end of the
project
there are also 14 what we call disease
connect home projects
that are also in late stages of
acquiring and
analyzing and sharing data altogether 4
000 subjects will be in
this collection of projects
on each project dealing with a
particular disorder depression psychosis
and so on and dan marcus and i have
spearheaded the connect on coordination
facility to handle the informatics
for these for processing them
systematically with
hcp style pipelines and providing the
data
making it ready for data sharing i'll
come back to the data sharing aspects in
a moment but i just want to touch upon a
couple of others
the abcde project is even more ambitious
it's a 10-year project to follow 12 000
kids from nine years
through the teenage decade
there's a baby connect home project
that's got exciting
data on very young ages a british
prenatal and
neonatal project uh the uk bio
bank project again pushing another
envelope a hundred thousand subjects
uh albeit with only 30 minutes of scan
per subject
so there's staggering amounts of
neuroimaging data being acquired shared
and analyzed and one of the key
events recently was an nih decision
that data sharing for these projects
rather than being
localized in institution-based
repositories
are in general going to be coming into a
a
cloud-based nimh data archive
and an aspiration
that nimh is pushing on
is that even for smaller projects
but projects of any side with imaging
genomic
and other modalities of data should be
planning to get their data into this nda
archive there's
some important issues to be worked out
for the community
to shift over to the this nda
cloud-based uh domain uh
the data access isn't as straightforward
as we were had been able to make it for
the young adult hcp but it is manageable
and nih is encouraging investigators
to get accustomed to working
on the cloud for data analysis that's
going to be developing rapidly in the
years to come
and i think the data science community
that you guys represent
can really play an invaluable service to
the community in helping
establish and that infrastructure
and make it robust for a wide variety
of analysis strategies on the cloud as
well as what one can do
by downloading the data and bring it
into the laboratory and
environment so to wrap it up uh
in brief summary we've seen evidence of
the importance of looking at cortical
particulation uh great progress
in many species particularly humans and
mice
uh i've given you a strong
indications of how extraordinarily
complex cortical connectivity
is uh but it's an organized uh
set of networks in a distributed
hierarchical configuration
uh neuroinformatics which jack and i
have been engaged in for
literally decades has gone from
a an outlier out in the boondocks
domain of science to a front burner
exciting field of research that
again you guys are helping to spearhead
and there's a tremendous amount to be
done
using the new tools applied to
these very rich data sets particularly
the hcp style
that i've emphasized it gives a lot of
value added for studying development
aging
brain disorders and will give us
progress in the future
so one quick analogy just to drive some
of these points home
we have classical maps of the earth and
the brain book atlases and
the brain and earth satellite imagery
was revolutionary
mri is revolutionary for brain imaging
google earth as you
know has been utterly transformative uh
that and other technologies for
navigating at
an immense rate range of scales
seamlessly and literally at your
fingertips
we look forward to continued exciting
project
progress and in the field of atomics to
let us navigate
the brain at the immense range of
spatial scales that are needed to
decipher
its organization and function so what
i've been able to tell you about is
due to tremendous efforts by people in
my lab
our collaborators henry and takuya a
fantastic team of individuals for the
young adult hcp
and the successor lifespan projects and
the generous support of
funding agencies so i'd be happy to
discuss
any questions that you may have david
thank you so much for sharing with us
this
really it's a tour de force amount of
work to
map the brain and its form and function
both from
some of your early work that which you
you summarize but also this just
impressive
amount of science that has been born
out of the human connectome project and
all of its
derivative projects um it's just so
exciting as
a source for data and an opportunity for
computational types to dive into that
data to model it to
be able to synthesize it and turn it
into new knowledge and
i i want to encourage our um
innovation lab participants to send in
any chats that you have for dr vanessa
via the
zoom chat feature um while we're waiting
for some of those to pile up
david i want to ask you that kind of as
you noted i think it was kind of a
general
thread throughout your talk was that the
brain possesses
multiple scales of measurement and
multiple scales of resolution
from cells to systems from synapses to
cortical shapes from you know time
as well as spatial aspects and
while many researchers tend to stick
within their particular
space show temporal slice of area of
research
what do you are you envisioning or can
you tell from the human connectome
project
what we need to do to actually transcend
some of these scales of measurement and
what sort of data science might be
needed in order to do that
my short answer is i think it's a great
opportunity
uh and my instincts are
that we need literally a new approach a
new brand of
computational strategies and and data
science
to grapple uh with
these utterly daunting challenging
but critical issues of
navigating across scales in a way that
captures
the way that these brain networks
somehow
manage to work i've been very interested
in computational neuroscience
since literally uh the mid-80s
and have been excited to see progress
uh on many fronts including efforts uh
to
to bridge this gap between micro miso
macro scales as we one of the ways we
can parse that
but i also my feeling is
that we haven't really broken
through the ice and and
gotten into uh a rich
exploratory strategy that
uh yields uh the the
the deep pay dirt uh it it's partly
because we don't have the computational
tools
yet there
i think there's tremendous room for
innovation on
strategies for modeling complex networks
that
that have to be invented i i don't feel
like
it's just a matter of taking existing
tools and and running with it
we need smart people
developing new computational strategies
in conjunction uh with the ability to
cope with these staggering amounts
of data that i've touched upon
from these multimodalities so
i've i've made the point uh uh
okay on occasion that when i was in a
student
a postdoc in the 1970s working with
hubel and weasel
i had this absolute illusion
that they had stolen or not stolen they
had just
taken the the cream of what's to be
discovered in neuroscience
and published it and got their nobel
prize and what was left for us to mop
up was just uh uh leftovers
and nothing could be farther from the
truth i i've come to realize
they deserve their nobel prize they and
many other pioneers
uh but what we have yet to understand
about the brain
keeps looming larger and larger the more
we know the more there is to
that we really have to uh
have yet to learn in terms of the data
and
uh deciphering how it actually works
so it's tremendously exciting and will
be so
for literally decades to come
david you've been involved with various
aspects of
the sharing of data for as long as i
have known you
and the there's a sociology behind
sharing which i think in the early days
was
almost uh just crippling people were
just so nervous about doing it and
now it almost seems like it's just
expected that you do it
and i'm just curious if you have any war
stories or uh thoughts about how
data have kind of become fair as you
know
capital f-a-i-r um and what lessons you
have learned from the human connect dome
project
patience i would say is one of the
things that you and i both had to learn
because uh i think we both acutely
recall
those early days it was an uphill battle
and
and we were in another analogy
voices in the wilderness saying hey guys
it's really really important to share
data and and
uh as you kind of alluded to we would
get anything from
blank stares to struggle with shoulders
do resistance
hostility i don't want to do it don't
bother me to
[Music]
i'd love to do it i have no idea how and
indeed
knowing how back in those days was
impractical so
i i i think you and i and many others
have had to be patient uh
with the
evolution of the methodology as well as
the sociology
uh to where we now are at long last
uh a couple of decades later
um the the the attitude
is radically different in in the
community in the younger generation
and indeed is saying of course we should
share and
how do we do it how do we help but um
taking the long view has been important
for folks like you and me
well i couldn't agree more one final
question before we wrap things up is
uh what do you see as the role of the
understanding
of both structural and functional
connectivity
in understanding neurological disease
uh again it's hugely important
um i think
you know there have been hypotheses for
example
that certain disorders schizophrenia or
autism
are exemplified by quote over
connectivity or under connectivity
as suggested by fmri particularly
wrestling state fmri or other uh
the idea tracktography as well
to me those are yeah
a first crack at trying to
crack the nut and get down to the the
meat of the issue
i think is exceedingly unlikely that the
the
neurological disorders will be explained
in such a simple way
and that's one of the reasons why i'm
intensely interested
in exploring how one can take
resting state fmri data as powerful and
enticing as it is and
probe it more deeply and beyond just
looking at simple correlations
or even partial correlations which we've
tried and doesn't actually help as much
as we
might have hoped in kind of cleaning up
the
the signal and and getting better
estimates of
actual uh wiring like connectivity
so i think we need animal models
and we need an intense commitment by the
field to say
we've got to go way past correlation and
figure out
somehow using better data and better
analysis
strategies to infer uh what does this
these what do these signals tell us and
how do we interpret them
in much more nuanced and complicated
sophisticated ways as to what the
malfunction dysfunctions are in
brain disorders like autism
schizophrenia and many others
david with that let me thank you very
much for sharing
uh this amazing body of work with us
and uh giving us some words of wisdom as
we uh kind of undertake our own
interests here in
uh neuroscience uh neuroimaging
neuroscience
generally across spatial and temporal
scales thank you so much
i really appreciate it and i want to
wish everybody who's listening in a very
good weekend and once again dr venison
thank you so much
thank you my pleasure